it's dope too man because I feel like
you're in a really rare position where
you know a lot of people might have had
your journey in this music industry and
like been discouraged or allowed it to
like I'm sure at times it was like
mentally taxing for you but it feels
like man you're coming out on the other
side of like this [ __ ] I appreciate what
I'm saying yeah do you feel like
musically you're in the best space
you've been in a long time in terms of
just being creative and yeah we're
definitely being able to be Zone them
with myself before I'm saying like I had
a um I was in a relationship and [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying just got out
that situation positive or negative
toxic not toxic Christian rock blue face
type of [ __ ]
but it was you know I mean you know I
had you know I had to just get my vibes
I feel like I had to give myself you
know what I'm saying like word you know
decided to really stand myself man and
just build up pandemic it was just a
little different you know what I'm
saying like
I felt like I was doing my I was seeing
myself in the same cycle that's what me
and shorty like kind of like separated
at that time you feel me he wasn't as
close to as much so it was just like you
know she on the East Coast I'm on the
west coast right I'm out here I'm
building the crib out you know what I'm
saying doing [ __ ] with the crib so I
just was like more alone if I'm saying
to myself and then from that you know I
mean flights all that stuff covet people
being separated and it's like you know I
mean we just became like more like this
distance if I'm saying and then right I
feel like it was a good thing though for
real because it changed me bro that's
where this you know the journey
psychedelic started yeah I'm saying it
started seeing life from from small from
the ant to
from the plant to you know what I mean
to the way I'm eating you know what I'm
saying to how I fix my diet how I fix my
mom you're vegan now yeah you feel me
hold up how long has that been no no
word for the system um beginning of the
pandemic I'll be doing the you know I
mean the chicken noodle soups all day
we're first pan in the cabin I was going
over there the Olive Garden and chicken
noodle soup of course
it was funny bro funny man but
definitely definitely man I had the uh
full vegan yeah and you and you feel
good yeah what what do you miss what
food do you miss the most though oh man
your phone saying I ain't gonna lie man
you ain't gonna get me started man
you're gonna give me started he tried to
give me back in my graveyard man you
mistake you what do you missed what's
the one thing if you could have one
cheat meal
Oreo milkshake and Oreo milkshake yeah
that's right you can't have a milkshake
because you're vegan so my guy right
there is vegetarian so he's still he's
still no no not him
so Cyrus vegetarian so he still has milk
and cheese and [ __ ] yeah I'm not but I I
ain't like you know I mean what would
inspired you to be vegan was it like
because you love animals or because it
was a health thing I hope situation Rob
was on stage with fun flex you can see
it show me just vomiting on stage if I'm
standing in the middle of the show a
couple shows like if I'm saying word
even with Alyssa was it because you were
out of shape is it were you drunk or yo
I noticed when I'm eating meat that's a
lot of acid overload yeah and if I'm
doing liquor and all that [ __ ] that ass
to start building up like I'm saying
crazy so yeah like I started to notice
some moments and I just took it easy I
just take it easy with that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] for me it'd be [ __ ] me up even
in my sleep I was over there like waking
up out of sleep like oh [ __ ] throwing up
throwing them about the guy [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying have you uh calmed
down on drinking what's up you know I
mean it's a Vibe it's a creative it's a
creative tool I'll use it as a creative
tool yeah
do you feel like you ever had a problem
drinking yeah it was like you're
drinking too much no no that's good
that's not my vibe yeah I mean I I I
mean my parents they was alcoholic you
know what I'm saying so and they out
that situation you told me by the grace
of God you know and right man so I seen
that [ __ ]
young up close a little bit before